5 26 on your friday morning what's cool
at school how about dozens of ccsd
students who live near the dollar loan
center in henderson well they don't have
to go far to show off their sports
related artwork
as part of national art in education
week the henderson silver knights and
ccsd's community engagement folks showed
off a two-story stairwell mural made up
of 62 students art that's all about the
silver knights their parent club the
golden knights and the indoor football
nighthawks
students excited to find their name on a
big plaque to find their art and have
their family there to enjoy the evening
silver knights general manager tim
speltz was impressed variety detail and
you can see uh you know how proud they
are of their artwork with hockey
training camp right around the corner
one of the silver nights broadcasters
brian mccormick had a question for
speltz about maybe getting the players
involved should we break out some
crayons and paper and see if they can
match this i don't think they can match
this no i think they're fine with hockey
sticks i don't think that's going to
work thanks tim enjoy the day
probably a good take there tim by the
way henderson's ccsd students are also
competing to design a silver knights
logo that's going to end up on actual
game jerseys we'll be sure to follow up
on that and we always want to know
what's cool at school if you've got
something let us know cool at school
under the community tab at 8newsnow.com
or just email
coolantschooland8newsnow.com